because like now you're i mean you've
always been like popping in la right but
like
you're also now like a media personality
mm-hmm so now you kind of experience
what him and i probably experience i've
been doing radio 609 so
[ __ ] sending you their mixtape
or running up on you
yeah
adjusted to that i had i had to get just
i was turned up on [ __ ] he was just
like hey bro cocky there i said i don't
do no interviews
and people get so they take [ __ ] so
personal bro when you're just like
it's just crazy like the the lack of
tact
or common sense that artists have is
crazy
and entitlement oh entitlement is number
one entire rappers are so [ __ ]
entitled break i don't even know who you
are bro like like what like you i'ma
just bring you on my [ __ ] like
what like what like and bro everybody
like
like 80 of the artists and people told
me i shouldn't do no jumper i shouldn't
do media and nothing like that now like
bro that was the best [ __ ] move i'm
like y'all [ __ ] is stupid bro it's
like why wouldn't you do
you know if you could have the
personality and all the opportunities
are here why wouldn't you put yourself
on camera and i feel dumb not doing [ __ ]
sooner not vlogging now you know what
i'm saying now i look at [ __ ] like him
now i be like okay instead of just
playing video games at the house why
don't i [ __ ] film this [ __ ] get some
great content monetize that [ __ ] and
it's like every single aspect is like
now business mind is like okay
let me get a buck for this let me get a
buck for this let me get a buck for this
and it kind of takes away like the play
time from it it's like okay if i'm not
getting paid like even now like i go out
what i'm hosting you know i mean like
and if [ __ ] life's been better i got
more [ __ ] money i'm not making dumb
ass purchases and [ __ ] like that and i
feel like that respect level too has
gone way up yeah i would all you know
for just like
you know shout outs ahead but me and
edward always like man a.d be putting
out so much ill [ __ ] but like he'd be
[ __ ]
exposing himself to the marketplace
so like when he drops [ __ ] it's like
like you're at every club everywhere
i'm excited to see what it's like when
you put your new [ __ ] out because yeah
he hasn't put up project in like two
years and i feel like the no jumper
audience is actually like really primed
to like i know support was it was it the
blue rhino [ __ ] last [ __ ] you dropped
that was like that was an ep but i mean
like in the interim of everything bro i
mean by the way those work yeah they
work good yeah me and pun we look too
good yeah me and pum bought our own
bought a studio you know what i'm saying
so i i got the the time to like one
thing that this [ __ ] showed me is that
okay i can film and do all this stuff
but i get to take my time with music
don't have to rush anything yeah i mean
and just really get the best material
out of the situation and it's like i'm
coming back with some of the biggest
producers in music you know what i mean
i got new fans you know i mean i still
like crazy ass features like everything
is primed and i'm like [ __ ] ain't
[ __ ] on my [ __ ] and you could really
rap how many people yeah people give you
credit as like a mc because i've heard
some [ __ ] i'm like yeah this is a.d we
went to the studio with him one time and
just watching him like put a verse
together i'm like oh man i totally
forget from hanging out with this guy
and seeing him act like an idiot then
he's really good